grab your sweetie and beg for
forgiveness because it's episode 8 of
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina and
this one's got murder episode 8 begins
with a healthy breakfast of all bacon
for Ambrose who had to miss out on the
human buffet from last episode Sabrina
on the other hand is off meat for a
while after Harvey's shift in the chef's
Minds he and Sabrina are set for a movie
date and Ambrose mentions he'll soon be
able to do the same apparently Luke has
connections with a high priest and is
looking into getting his house arrest
overturn Zelda comes in searching for
Hilda when the phone rings there's been
an accident of the mines and Harvey was
inside at the mines the whole town is
gathered in response to the collapse
Sabrina rushes through the crowd
desperately trying to find Harvey and
he's okay but five guys aren't they're
stuck in the mine and Tommy's one of
them as Roz and Susie dish out soup for
the volunteers Harvey emerges from his
search for Tommy and I do believe that's
Ross's dad leading the town people in
prayer there's bad news the entrance
leading to the trap miners is too small
for anyone to get through even Harvey
Susie hears that and what we don't see
is that her ancestor Dorothea Putnam has
appeared once more and tells her she's
the right size to squeeze through when
people find out she made it into the
mine a crowd begins to gather and Susie
emerges carrying one broken miners hat
Tommy's this homies that we did we find
him oh my sweet so much had Harvey not
ready to give up wishes to keep
searching for his brother
but daddy kinkle puts a stop to it the
faster they dig without the proper
equipment the more likely the mine will
begin to collapse further
father-of-the-year ladies and gents that
night Harvey opens up about the events
in the mind and that Tommy helped save
his life by pushing him out of the way
then somehow the tunnel held just long
enough for Harvey to escape if you
remember in episode 7 Sabrina put a
protection spell on Harvey after the
weird sisters got all blood for blood
when the kinkle skilled a familiar
Harvey laments that the first 12 hours
are the most crucial in a mine collapse
after that your chances are slim to none
the next morning Sabrina and Hilda
returned from a night of comforting
townfolk when zelda merges with more bad
news
Ambrose astral projected into the mines
and found no survivors but
Brina can't tell anyone that's the
burden of being a witch in the mortal
world having information you can never
relay to them
harvey is ready to continue the search
for tommy when he walks in on mr. kinkle
going through life insurance papers with
a man from the bank dad is calling off
the search in order to spare any further
loss of life and of course collect
Tommy's insurance policy
I'm uh pretty fond of you and Harvey's
pissed dad's already planning Tommy's
funeral for tomorrow because he can't
collect the money until the death is
finalized at the academy Nick is
concerned about Sabrina's absence when
Agatha and orcas tell them there was an
accident the minds and that a bunch of
mortals died Nick is lying in the
complaint friend that would be terrible
sorry Nick Harvey still kicking door
katha then gloat over Tommy's death
which prudence overhears she's either
upset because of her newfound friendship
with Sabrina or because she feels left
out probably both before the funeral
Sabrina asks Hilda what happens when you
die after all Zelda has killed her many
times she can only speak to a witches
experience as for mortals she doesn't
know naturally Sabrina wonders if
there's a way to bring Tommy back like
Hilda has done but the only reason Hilda
has been revived is because of the
Spellman family's special plot of soil
apparently it was soil from the garden
of Cain and soaked in the blood of Abel
and any who are buried in it come back
to life the story of Cain and Abel is
one of the Bible's oldest and is very
reflective of the relationship Zelda and
Hilda have Cain and Abel were the first
two sons of Adam and Eve the brothers
made sacrifices to God but God favoured
Abel's sacrifice instead of Cain's Cain
then murdered Abel at a jealousy
whereupon God punished Cain to a life of
wandering never to be killed and only to
live with his guilt we saw this story
back in episode 5 reflected in Zelda's
nightmare but Cain's garden strictly for
witches at the funeral everyone's
showing up including dr. C and even miss
ward well Roz sings a hymn titled blest
be the tie that binds and Sabrina cast
another spell and Harvey to give him the
strength to speak talk about a
controlling girlfriend mister kinkle
gets up and says how much Tommy loved
the mines which really sets Harvey off
mr. Hinkle's all like boy boy boy
the to tussle and oops the casket gets
knocked open Oh pops the only thing they
have left of Tommy his mining hat
outside Harvey shows Sabrina and
acceptance letter Tommy got from Notre
Dame a football scholarship
full ride Tommy could have escaped their
town and the mines but Harvey thinks he
stayed to protect him and blames Tommy's
death on himself
then mr. kinkle comes in with some kind
words you father of the year then Zelda
uses a spell to stop him from hitting
his child at doctor services Sabrina and
miss ward well unpacked the events of
the funeral Sabrina's ward well she
knows of any resurrection spells to
bring Tommy back and spare Harvey's
suffering miss ward well let Sabrina
know life and death are not things to be
trifled with before casually mentioning
the spell is super duper easy to do and
there's a Book of the Dead just waiting
to be stolen in our office at Baxter
high but even if she wanted to do it the
spell requires an offering to the Dead
something to balance the life gained
someone has to die for Tommy to live
again and Sabrina's no killer right at
the Spellman's father blockwood has
dropped in to visit Ambrose regarding
his house arrest
apparently Ambrose went to Oxford and
was a poet painted with the Surrealists
and taught stage magic to Houdini in
episode 5 I mentioned that Ambrose must
have a history as a scholar due to the
shakespeare he spoke in his nightmare
Blackwood wonders how after all this he
came to a plot to blow up the Vatican
Ambrose's father died when he was young
and Ambrose drifted to all these places
in search of a father figure before
eventually he found one a young growly
in reference to a man named Aleister
Crowley a famous English occultist
ceremonial magician poet novelist
painter and Satanist it's not clear if
Ambrose is referring to the actual
Aleister Crowley as his mentor or a man
just like him either way it led him to a
plot to blow up the Vatican and Ambrose
was the only witch arrested for it
Faustus says if Ambrose gives up the
names of the others involved he'll have
his freedom the four Faustus leaves
Zelda stops him and is in need of some
spiritual guidance it's time for satanic
confession Zelda's afraid her family has
strayed too far from the path of night
Edward Spellman married a mortal she has
a half mortal niece Hilda's been
excommunicated and Ambrose is under
house arrest and it all begins to make
sense why Zelda has been so strict about
following which law she's Jesper
trying to restore the Spellman's image
within the coven and Faustus has a
confession of his own he's got something
for Zelda Lady Blackwood hasn't been
addressing his needs while pregnant and
that just won't do Susie gets another
visit from Dorothea who's pleased with
Susie's trips into the minds calling her
a very brave boy in Episode seven I
mentioned browses blonde Anna calling
Susie a fella and that possibly her true
self identifies Ismail Dorothea called
Susie's venture into the mind just the
beginning in Harvey's room were witness
to one of the most shocking events yet
in the show he declines a call from
Sabrina at Baxter hi Ross confesses that
when she picked up Tommy's helmet at the
funeral her cunning gave her a vision
one that showed The Weird Sisters dork
at the smashing dolls in the minds weird
right yeah definitely weird in the woods
Sarita summons prudence to enlist her
help in getting revenge on door katha
after all she Oh Sabrina after saving
Prue from the feast and Sabrina has a
plan Sabrina and prudence confront the
two sisters who essentially admit to the
whole thing crew goes all drill sergeant
claims that whoever was the ringleader
will pay the price and if neither
confess they'll both pay it takes Dorcas
about three seconds to throw Agatha
under the bus you can take that fake
apology and shove it right up your head
I'm just sorry the other kinkle Boyd
didn't die - and Nick's coming - so
Sabrina sneaks into Ward Will's office
for the book of the Dead and naturally
Wardwell is in her favorite spot
skulking in the shadows in the woods the
gang set up a pentagram to sacrifice
Agatha and resurrect Tommy first Sabrina
calls on the hounds guardians of the
door to help with the resurrection this
is likely in reference to hellhounds
protectors of the supernatural with
Cerberus being the most famous example
next they must open the door between
worlds and finally time for the
sacrifice Wardwell watches on the side
and my guess is that performing a
resurrection isn't as simple as Sabrina
thinks that when the time comes Wardwell
will ensure it works
Sabrina puts the knife to egg at the
throat but of course Sabrina isn't a
killer
Oh Oh God after one final incantation
the ritual is complete
seeing Wardwell stumble here makes me
believe she used a great deal of energy
to ensure the ritual actually worked all
she really wanted was to see sabrina
become corrupted enough to actually
murder someone but Sabrina's got a plan
wait 13 minutes for all the traces of
witch to leave Agatha's body then bury
her in the cane soil of course
Ambrose comes rushing in fiercely
scolding Sabrina death does not take
kindly to being cheated and the
imbalance this will cause could be
catastrophic but Sabrina holds her
ground
this spell said nothing about the
sacrifice having to stay bad and Agatha
wakes no turning back now all we have to
do is wait thirteen hours for Tommy to
come back to earth see how everything's
going according to plan
infamous Wyatt's cousin the next morning
Zelda is looking very pleased all of a
sudden good on Faustus for not being a
selfish lover as Sabrina waits for the
thirteen hours to pass she asked Roz
about her vision Rossville Sabrina in on
the cunning and how it was apparently
coming from a witch's curse crazy right
meanwhile Blackwood is back to here if
Ambrose is ready to snitch when Ambrose
refuses Blackwood is very pleased at his
show of integrity honor and loyalty and
offers Ambrose a lighter sentence in
exchange for him working with him at the
academy from there they can figure out a
way on how to pardon him perhaps
Blackwood was listening when Ambrose
said he'd been searching for a father
figure something Blackwood will surely
use to his advantage as he goes to leave
Zelda's waiting for round two she first
shows him a twin headed snail an omen
that Faustus is going to have twin boys
to celebrate they flagellate themselves
I guess these guys were into the kinky
stuff after the 13 hours are up Sabrina
goes to check at the ritual site but
nothing's happened when she brings it up
to Ambrose he mentions Tommy soul
wouldn't go to the effigy but back to
the body back in the mines
Sabrina races over to the mines only to
find the entrance way broken open at the
kinkle house it's another night of TV
dinners when there's a knock at the door
slowly ominously it continues knock
knock here's Tommy thanks everyone for
watching we're close to wrapping of the
season only two more episodes to go
so stay tuned and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe until then keep walking that
path of night